مباني مدمره محلات تساوت بالارض والاخرى
بقيت صامده عدا نوافذها المحطمه يتسابق من
بقي في هذه المدن المتضرره من الزلزال الى
اكوام من الصناديق البعض بحثا عن
الاحتياجات الاساسيه
واخرون استغلوا الوضع الصعب للسرقه والنهب
هنا نرى من يخرج راكضا من محل تجاري بيده
اساسيات غذائيه او استهلاكيه
وبالمقابل مشهد لاخرين يخرجون اما خليل
وفاض او بغنائمه كبيره مهما كانت اسباب
ومبررات اولئك الاشخاص الذين وثقت سرقاتهم
عبر مقاطع فيديو ملات مواقع التواصل الا
ان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد انه
لهم بالمرصاد مستنكرا استغلال البعض
للظروف الصعبه الحاليه
مع الاسف هناك بعض الناس الذين يهاجمون
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه وينهبون
والمواد الدوله اتخذت التدابير وخطوات
ضدها هؤلاء وستتم معاقبتهم باشد الطرق
الرئيس التركي اعلن قبل ايام حاله الطوارئ
في البلاد لمده ثلاثه اشهر حاله قال انها
ستساهم في مساعده المدن المنكوبه والحد من
اعمال النهب والسرقه
روان حمزه العربيه